hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video sehen schon ich befinde mich in
meinem wohnzimmer allerdings richtig
entsteht kein tisch unter hat sondern
der c4 romantische hingestellt und so
quasi so ein bisschen als tor deklariert
stell dir vor das sie ist ein fußball
zur änderung ist die sache das ist in
die puschen und wir haben einen großen
ball das spielprinzip hier ist quasi
einfach land schießen kennen glaube ich
jeder habe ich ja sogar schon mal mit
dir hochgeladen ich mal besser mein t
shirt da auf dem boden
also jeder hat gleichfalls zehn schüsse
und das ziel des spiels ist es die latte
so oft wie möglich zu treffen und der
verlierer bekommt wasser ins gesicht
gesprüht mehr brauchen wieder mehr
wachstum machen wenn es hier schießen
gemacht haben haben wir nämlich jeweils
leben was auch schon gestellt und muss
nicht wir unterstützen also ist in der
beschreibung verlinkt das hier ist die
linie als man muss dahinter bleiben und
dann falls mit diesem ball
die latte dorthin treffen wieder nicht
gefragt so leid von dexters ok kurze
distanz lisa war der ball ist halt echt
kann ihn überhaupt nicht einschätzen wie
schießen wird plötzlich ist da drüben zu
kommen steht anfang nicht die ganze noch
zwei schüsse passieren einmal getroffen
werden schon wieder nicht
entschuldigen die linie
also ich muss man zweimal treffen
deswegen würde ich sagen dass direkt in
ersten schüssen
[Musik]
das war nicht leicht darüber wie es zu
feiern wir gefallen wünscht
[Musik]
die gute bestrafungen küche zu finden
gedacht ist es echt schwer alles alter
nicht alleine getroffen bisher ist das
meine damen herren der kassiert wird
wird geschnitten und gezählt okay mein
letzter job ich kann jetzt noch bewähren
[Musik]
kommen die bestrafung für max sein name
gilt das was ihr vom video meine damen
und herren es euch gefallen hat was
gerne den leib damals video was du für
sein kann aufgenommen haben jetzt unten
in der beschreibung verlinkt